All right, now we know that 3 colorability is NP hard.
If I give you a general graph and say--can you assign colors to these nodes, at most three colors
to these nodes so that no two nodes that are connected have the same color.
Answering that yes or no for all possible graphs is probably computationally intractable.
It's as hard as any problem in NP. What is that tell us about 4 colorability.
So I want you to check all the things that are true because we know that 3 colorability is an NP,
then 4 colorability is an NP because we can quickly verify a certificate that list the color assignments.
So is it true that 4 colorability is an NP for this reason.
It's not necessarily an NP because the number of colors is bigger than in the 3 colorability case.
Is is the case that it is not necessarily NP hard
because having four colors to work with makes things easier.
So just because something is hard to color with three colors,
it could be quite easy to color with four colors.
Next, no, no--it is NP hard because the solution to 4 colorability also solves 3 colorability
and the reason for that is we can just add another node to the graph,
connect it to all the other ones and then try to color that graph, and then finally, since any graph
that is 3 colorable is 4 colorable, the problems are basically equivalent, so it's the same.
So check all that apply. There are two of them that apply.